♪♪
-I'm 73 years old.
And if you can be this --
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I find out things about myself
when I say them.
-I'm a recovering politician.
-Ugh-ah!
Every time I listen to "Let it
Go" it's like, yeah!
How you feeling?
A little overwhelmed?
-It's good, I'm good.
-Alright good. Thank you.
How do you pass the time
when you spend two months
near a fishign village?
-There were two pretty
highly professional sex shops.
-Two sex shops?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Were they just selling
a lot of fisherman stuff?
-In the sex shop?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I-I don't know.
My wife, like when I come in
with a big yellow slicker,
my wife is like ya-ya-ya-ya-ya.
-The film is called "21
Bridges," but this is not
the original title of it,
though.
-The film originally was called
"17 Bridges."
-Wow!
-At some point during filming
they realized there might be
more than 17.
-It does seem like sometone
should have checked off the top.
-You'd have thought that maybe--
-Yeah I don't want to be
judgemental or anything.
-I'm just calling it
"Several Bridges."
-You know, you were in the White
House the last time there was
an impeachment going on.
What is your take?
-It's so fun to remember
those days.
-I know, right?
Just good old times.
The '90s right?
Remember the '90s?
Republicans decided to change
their arguement again.
My, God, look how much their
argument has changed.
This would be like if you got
pulled over and said,
"I wasn't speeding. Okay I was
speeding. Everyone speeds.
I was late for my job, I work at
the hospital, so does my wife.
And she's having a baby and I
was barely speeding.
Fire I was really speeding and
my wife's not pregnant.
And I don't have a wife.
And also I'm drunk on cocaine."
Gordon Sondland was so
determined to bring down Trump,
he didn't even need anyone else
in the room with him.
he could've just interviewed
himself.
"Mr. Sondland, was there a quid
pro quo?"
"Yes, Mr. Sondland, there was.
And that's the tea."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, one of the things we
all know about Mr. Rogers
is onecessary of the things we
all know about Tom Hanks,
which is, he's actually as
lovely as he seems.
Uh, it's kinda crazy though,
right?
-Yes. I'm now almost at the
point of going,
when do I start a new rumor?
-Yeah.
-Just saying about I'm gonna
take down Hanks.
-Yeah.
-Just like full-time bad guy.
-I mean, I'll do both.
I'm take down Rogers,
and Hanks.
-The inspiration fro "Jolene,"
if I'm correct,
was a bank teller?
-Well, yeah.
It was a girl
that worked at the bank.
She had everything I didn't.
Like legs and stuff.
You know, and tall, beautiful.
And he was just spending a lot
of time down there.
And I thought. I know we ain't
got that kind of money.
That was kind of the set-up
for "Jolene,"
of course became famous.
-A giant famous song.
And what would you do today if
you ran into another Jolene
with your husband?
-Oh, with my husband?
-Yeah.
-I'd just hide his Viagra.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The king of France --
-The king of France?
-Lois XIV.
-Okay.
-He wanted edible pears because,
like, fruit was like
a real luxury.
-Edible pears.
Were pears just in paintings
before then?
-He ate a pear and he
ejaculated.
-What?! Pear!
-So I feel like --
-You nasty!
-Instead of Viagra,
just get a pear.
[ Laughter ]